The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
you know the drill
from the previous
couple of weeks.
Get your piece of paper out,
and write down what you think
were important concepts
for the last week or so.
OK.
Let's see what you
have on your papers.
AUDIENCE: Center of mass can be
used to find the total force.
PROFESSOR: So the concept
is center of mass and things
you can use it for.
So I'm going to generalize
that to "systems of particles."
And what you've just
said is, center of mass
is one thing that
comes from that.
Anybody, on this subject
of systems of particles,
anybody else have something?
AUDIENCE: Angular momentum?
PROFESSOR: Angular momentum.
So what about it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this concept
of the summation of the hi's,
equal to H at the system,
and that you can use that.
Anything else about systems
of particles that we learned?
AUDIENCE: Newton's third
law between the particles?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
Newton's third law
can help to support things
out, and a consequence-- you
found center of
mass, that's useful,
but you take the derivative
of the center of mass,
what do you find out?
rG here, dot times the
total mass is what?
AUDIENCE: Momentum?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's momentum,
but it's momentum of what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, it's the
momentum of the entire system,
right?
And so this is the
summation of the Pi.
That's kind of important.
And finally, take
another derivative,
what did you learn about that?
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Forces?
PROFESSOR: What kind of forces?
AUDIENCE: External.
PROFESSOR: All the external
forces are in the system.
All of them.
So powerful things came out of
thinking about center of mass.
All right, what's
something else we
did in the week that wasn't
around systems of particles?
Yes.
Actually, say your name
when I call on you,
I'm gonna try to learn
more of your names.
AUDIENCE: Christina.
PROFESSOR: Christina, right.
AUDIENCE: So, when you're
looking at equations,
for example, like
the force external
is equal to the change
in angular momentum.
Looking at what
pieces go where, so
if you have a defined
moment, does it
go on this side or that side?
PROFESSOR: OK, and I'd put that
in the category of free body
diagrams, are you thinking of?
So, constructing
free body diagrams.
OK, what else?
AUDIENCE: Eddie.
PROFESSOR: Eddie?
AUDIENCE: The two different
methods for finding torque.
PROFESSOR: So, let's go a
little further with torque.
What do you use the torque for?
What do you want
to find torque for?
To get-- let's generalize
this to equations of motion,
so both for forces, and moments.
Two different kinds
of problems that we
are able to do by being
able to find the torques.
Anything else?
It's important this week.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I mean,
this isn't a math course.
Yeah, you've got to be able to
solve differential equations,
yeah.
Maybe you're actually
onto something here,
but let's put it in the context
of what kind of equations
we work on a lot on this week.
What kind of
equations of motion?
I don't mean like
second order linear,
I mean we're doing dynamics.
We're doing dynamics
of what kind?
AUDIENCE: Acceleration?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but also,
a lot of examples this week,
were they rotational problems
or translational problems?
AUDIENCE: Rotational?
PROFESSOR: Right, kind of
a heavy emphasis this week
on angular momentum, right?
So, using-- That's
a pretty good list.
My own list had
most of that on it.
Let's see where my list was.
Center of mass, r
dot, r double dot.
I wrote these as equations.
So this thing in
particular, the summation
of the external torques
with respect to some point,
for a particle, is dh
dt, plus vA, cross P.
And we were just beginning
to do sums of collections
of particles,
rigid bodies, where
you have maybe more
than one particle,
the summation of the
torques is the H-- capital
H-- for the summation of the h
of i's, dt plus vA in o cross,
and here's where we
learned something
up here that you can do down
here that was really helpful.
What crossed with what?
AUDIENCE: P.
PROFESSOR: Which P?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This
one up here, right?
And that's actually this.
So this is cross P of the
center of mass of the system.
OK good, that's a
pretty good list.
So now, let's do a problem.
So here's the problem.
It's a rigid rod, with
a mass on the end,
and the rod's massless just to
make it easy for the moment.
But this is now a rigid body.
There's a torsional spring here.
And the torsional spring
resists angular displacement
with a torque that's equal
to the spring constant times
the theta that you
push it through.
So it generates a moment,
a restoring moment.
When you push it away, it
tries to push this thing back.
Gravity is also acting, so
it's a pendulum as a rigid body
and a torsional spring.
So the first step-- I want
you to eventually find
the equation of motion.
And I want you to start by
doing a free body diagram.
But before you go
to work, I'm going
to give you a little quick
mini-lecture on free body
diagrams.
So, the first thing you
do is assign coordinates.
Maybe draw is not-- really
assign the coordinates
for the problem.
Determine the number
of degrees of freedom.
We haven't talked
about that much yet.
It will become much more
important in the subject.
The number of degrees of
freedom-- but I'll say it once,
and will do much
more with this--
the number of degrees of
freedom is the same thing
as the number of
independent coordinates
you need to completely
describe the motion.
And the number of
independent coordinates
that you need is equal to the
number of equations of motion
that you'll get.
So this problem, how many
coordinates does it take--
and this is planar motion,
it's confined to the board.
How many actual
coordinates does it
take to completely describe
the position of this thing?
I see a one, how
about-- anybody else?
What's the one?
What would you choose?
AUDIENCE: I think I'd
probably go with polar.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well
what coordinate itself?
What is the single
coordinate you
would use to define the
motion of the system?
I hear a theta.
Everybody agree?
Theta of t, if you can
figure out theta of t,
you know this position of
this thing for all time.
That's all you
need, is one degree
of freedom, one
coordinate, and in terms
of choosing the
coordinate system to use,
basically you were
saying, use what?
AUDIENCE: Polar
PROFESSOR: Polar
coordinates centered here.
But-- there's your
inertial system,
but you're going to
go with this point.
This is our A point,
and is it moving?
So if we use
expressions like this,
what will happen to that term?
It goes away.
AUDIENCE: So if you
were using Cartesian,
would it be two
degrees of freedom?
PROFESSOR: Nope.
And we'll get to that.
If I divert to that,
I won't finish what
I've got planned for today.
It's important and we're
going to come back to that.
Has to do with constraints.
So you assign the coordinates,
determine the number
of degrees of freedom,
assign positive values
to all rotations, displacements,
velocities, linear velocities,
and rotational velocities,
in the problem.
Positive values of those.
And from that, you
deduce the direction
of the resulting
forces and moments.
And this will help you
get the signs correct,
especially when you
have multi-body problems
like two masses with a
spring in between them.
Which way do the
forces go on each mass?
In this problem, there's
only one coordinate,
so what we're really saying
is assign a positive theta,
and assume a positive theta dot.
What are the resulting forces
that end up in your free body
diagram?
So now, I want you to
draw the free body diagram
for this thing, and up
here, final statement,
put in all forces and moments.
Don't leave out anything,
because you know
they're not going to matter.
Because it'll get you in
trouble as the problems
get more complicated.
OK, draw your free
body diagrams.
OK, so we're going to get
in groups of three or four,
and compare notes here.
You guys are kind
of a natural group--
check each other's stuff
and come up with a final.
AUDIENCE: We were having a
debate about whether or not
you were asking us for the free
body diagram of the system,
or if you were asking
us for the free body
diagram of the mass itself.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
are there moments
and things involved up here?
Like that torsional spring?
AUDIENCE: When you are including
the entire system there, yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
this is a rigid body.
I kept saying this
is a rigid body.
Happens to have a
single mass point in it,
but it's a whole,
single, rigid body.
And do the free body
diagram for the rigid body.
PROFESSOR: Can you
show me something?
Where are you at-- what's
your best shot at this so far?
AUDIENCE: The free body
diagram needs [INAUDIBLE].
And we say the spring force
is producing the moment.
PROFESSOR: So what's your
body that you're working with?
What's the definition
of a rigid body?
AUDIENCE: Mass on
the end of the rod?
PROFESSOR: OK, so you're still
thinking about the particle.
But if you don't think
about the particle,
it's kind of hard to get that
torsional spring involved.
So you need to think of this
as a single, whole body.
One whole, rigid body.
And now, just draw a stick in
here, and put the forces on it.
Doesn't matter where the
mass is for the purpose
of the free body diagram.
That comes into the--
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you
just use the r cross force?
And get the force in
the ball from the--
PROFESSOR: So you're
getting into the equation
of motion part of it.
This is only about assuming this
thing has some dynamic moment
in time, and draw the external
forces and moments that
act on the object.
And the object is this
full-length stick.
AUDIENCE: So in
that case, we just
have the spring force
acting, in opposition
to [INAUDIBLE] the weight?
PROFESSOR: You have
weight, for sure.
You have the spring, puts
a moment on the system,
and there are yet
potential other forces.
PROFESSOR: I'll give you a
couple minutes, because there's
a little confusion
around whether it's
a particle or a rigid body.
It's a rigid body.
You've got to deal
with the whole body.
All right, let's
see what you've got.
Where's your free body diagram?
AUDIENCE: This right here.
PROFESSOR: OK, tell me what you
have for forces and moments,
just point to each one of
'em and say what it is.
AUDIENCE: So, we have the
weight of the this end,
and we assume this is massless.
PROFESSOR: Yup, but it's rigid,
so it's all one system now,
you have one rigid body.
AUDIENCE: So the center
of mass is right here,
because there's-- [INAUDIBLE],
and then we have reaction
forces at the pin, and then we
have the moment from the spring
there.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: We have the
balls moving forever--
PROFESSOR: So, you've
gotta convince one
another who's right, here, so--
AUDIENCE: Well, it depends on
which way the ball's moving.
PROFESSOR: So, that's why
there is a little system.
There's a rubric that
I-- I recommend you just
use the system.
This is basically a system for
getting equations of motion,
and this is important, that one.
So then if you
know it's positive,
then you can figure out which
direction the reaction is.
All right, I hate
stopping all the fun.
You guys are doing well.
There is great value in
talking to one another,
and convincing one
another of what
the right way to
do something is.
You'll have two different points
of view, and talking it out,
It's amazing how fast
you can make progress.
So do that, do that when
you're home solving problems.
So what was the assignment here?
Draw a free body diagram.
Let's do it.
So it's a rigid body.
All one body, even though the
mass is all concentrated down
here, the forces-- what are
forces that are on this thing?
Give me one.
Wait, mg, right?
OK, what else?
AUDIENCE: Normal force?
PROFESSOR: Normal force.
Where?
AUDIENCE: On the top.
PROFESSOR: OK, so you're talking
about a reaction force up here?
And have you chosen
a coordinate system?
We already kind of
decided, didn't we,
on polar coordinates
for this, right?
So are the reaction
forces known?
To start with, no.
So what's the cleverest
way to assign them
on your free body diagram?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, and associated
with your coordinates, right?
So, I would have two
reaction forces up here, one
in each of which directions?
AUDIENCE: Radial.
PROFESSOR: Radial, and?
AUDIENCE: Tangential.
PROFESSOR: OK, and the positive
radial, positive tangential,
like that, right?
So I would say, I have
an unknown F theta force,
and I have an unknown FR
force, and I draw them
in the positive directions
because I have no clue.
So just make them positive.
You assume direction for them.
Force is here, g there,
what about the tension
in the string?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Does it
belong in this problem?
Why not?
The rigid body-- it's
an internal force.
It's the little
fij fji thing, it's
those things that cancel
internally, right?
So you don't have
to deal with it.
It's not an external
force to the rigid body.
So this is great.
The next step in this is to
find an equation of motion.
Gotta to be speedy about this.
So, what--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Moment.
PROFESSOR: Moment.
You'd use moment to do it.
About what point?
AUDIENCE: About the
point up at the top.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so if we call that A,
you'd use angular
momentum, and torques,
and that sort of thing?
Is that what you're saying?
Moments about it?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was
just wondering if you
were gonna draw it up on there.
PROFESSOR: No, I'm gonna
have you do it yourself.
Do it.
So now--
AUDIENCE: Well, is she talking
about how there's the moment--
the resistent moment.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Did we forget that one?
So which direction is it?
Clockwise, or counterclockwise?
AUDIENCE: It's clockwise.
PROFESSOR: All right, so there's
a moment about this point that
is-- we know what it is.
It's in that direction that
has value kt times theta.
Any time you know what it is,
don't just make it an unknown,
write it out.
You know it's that, and you
know it's in this direction.
And we're going to write--
how many equations of motion
will we get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And we've
chosen polar coordinates.
You could do this using forces.
Just Newton's second law.
But then you have
to solve for what?
If you write force
balance, F equals ma,
you have these up here,
and you don't know them.
So the reason to use
torques in this problem
is because, are these going
to appear in your answer?
No.
So that's the reason
to use torques.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that
k-- [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This is k
sub t to distinguish it
as a torsional spring.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
multiplied by L--
PROFESSOR: No, it doesn't
have an L, it's right here.
It's a spring who gives a moment
resistance to being deflected.
kt theta is units of torques.
And this isn't units of
force per unit displacement,
this is units of
torque per radian.
OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, you have
assigned polar coordinates,
and my assumption was
that-- I drew it right here.
There is positive theta hat.
Right?
AUDIENCE: So isn't
our torque negative?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But see, I've
drawn-- this negative
is accounted for by the
direction of the arrow.
So let's now write the
equation of motion,
and to do the
you're going to say that
the sum of the what?
AUDIENCE: Torques.
PROFESSOR: External torques.
About what point?
AUDIENCE: A.
PROFESSOR: A is equal to?
AUDIENCE: dH dt?
PROFESSOR: And I'll
use the capital H,
because we're now working
our way onto rigid bodies.
We could have more
than one point,
we could have more than
one mass point, dH dt plus?
AUDIENCE: v.
PROFESSOR: vA cross P, and
what's that in this problem?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: That guy
conveniently is 0.
So, do it.
You can now do this problem.
Figure out, write down
an equation of motion,
using some of external
torques and-- so
you're gonna have to
figure out angular
momentum and some torques.
I hate pulling you guys away.
Lots of good thinking going on.
All right, drag yourselves
away, help me out here.
Which groups figured out
the external torques?
What do you got?
Tell me what to do here.
AUDIENCE: We have
the one for gravity.
PROFESSOR: Tell me what it is.
I wanna write the terms down.
AUDIENCE: It is
negative Lmg sine theta.
PROFESSOR: Minus mgL sine
theta, in what direction?
AUDIENCE: k hat?
PROFESSOR: Others
agree with that term?
Hmm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Wait a second,
just one term at a time here.
The gravity term, do we
have the sign correct?
And then we have the
moment arm correct?
So this is the moment
arm, r cross force.
Looks like minus k to me.
mgL sine theta.
Looks pretty good.
What other torques?
AUDIENCE: The moment
from the spring.
PROFESSOR: Moment
Tell me how to write that.
AUDIENCE: That's in the negative
k hat section, so minus m hat.
Well, then [INAUDIBLE] kt theta.
PROFESSOR: kt theta,
also in k hat direction.
And our free body digram,
the forces produce moments.
Is everybody happy with that?
Are we done?
Any questions about it?
Why it's used the way it is?
OK.
Now we need this piece of it.
So what's the H?
For rigid body, the
summation of all the
bits-- how many bits are there?
Just the one.
And that's sum r,
cross P. Can somebody
tell me what they
got for the p, is
the momentum of our
little mass here,
with respect to an inertial
frame, which is also
A because it's not moving.
And r is L. So this is
L r hat cross m, what?
L, theta dot is its velocity,
mass times velocity,
and its direction?
Theta hat.
r cross theta is k,
so this looks like mL
squared theta dot k hat.
Are we all in agreement?
dH dt?
This k changed direction, so
the only time-dependent thing--
AUDIENCE: I think
you're missing a dot.
PROFESSOR: Oh, thank you,
we're going to need that.
All right, the derivative is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK,
that's equal to that.
It's all k's, you need just
one equation out of this,
you don't have to break it
down into subcomponents.
And you can collect
it all on one side.
mL squared theta double dot plus
kt theta plus mgL sine theta
equals 0.
And that's a second order
nonlinear ordinary differential
equation, which you could
linearize for small motion.
It's just a pendulum, OK?
Good.
We got one other one I want
to do before the hour's out.
I got a big piece of cement
pipe on the back of a truck.
It's not tied down.
The truck's moving at
3 meters per second.
And the rotation rate
of this piece of pipe
is 6 radians per second.
And the truck's
accelerating, minus 1/2
a meter per second squared.
It's actually breaking.
The guy's in trouble, right?
So the first thing here is--
omega 6 radians per second,
does it matter, with respect to
what, the truck or the ground?
I haven't told you.
Talk in your groups, and give
me a quick answer to that.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't matter.
PROFESSOR: Say again?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't matter?
PROFESSOR: So Kristen
thinks it doesn't matter.
Anybody wanna counter that?
Why not?
So, you're saying that this
could be omega with respect
to the truck?
Or it could be omega with
respect to this fixed frame,
and the answer will be
the same in either case?
Christine, right?
AUDIENCE: Christina.
PROFESSOR: Christina, alright.
AUDIENCE: So earlier,
we had that problem
with-- there was
an r, [INAUDIBLE]
and then there was another
[INAUDIBLE] over here.
You had to know what this
omega was with respect to what,
because this arm's
rotating also.
And so, with this, you have
your one xy-coordinate system,
and while the truck
is translating,
the truck's not gonna
be in rotation itself,
so it's staying in the
same coordinate plane,
and [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So your
argument is if you
were were standing on the
ground, seeing it rotating,
you'd say-- you would see
it rotated at the same rate
as if you were
riding on the truck.
Everybody agree with that?
Does it matter that the
truck's accelerating?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, it's only whether
or not the truck's rotating.
If the truck's not
rotating, then rotation rate
seen from this frame or
just a translating frame
will always seem the same.
Even if you're accelerating.
OK, so we've done that one.
Now, I want you to find the
velocity of point G, given
this information.
So, whip it down
quickly, how you
would approach this problem.
See if you can solve it.
G is the center of
mass of that big pipe.
OK, we're gonna run out of time.
Who's got an answer for me?
I think they've
got it sorted out.
Kristen?
AUDIENCE: So, we have
velocity of the truck, minus
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right,
so let's be systematic.
You have to pick some
points, and did you
use a rotating frame?
Use an equation that requires
a rotating reference frame?
AUDIENCE: No, because the
translational [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So I
assume you're talking
about-- we're looking at
the velocity of G in o,
is equal to, in general,
the velocity of some point
A that you're
gonna have to pick,
plus the velocity of
G with respect to A.
And this thing has two
possible components, right?
One which is the derivative of
GA, dt, ignoring the rotation,
plus-- OK.
What's this term
in this problem?
Well, we haven't picked
the point A. Where
are you going to pick point A?
There's dumb points,
and there's good points.
What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Front of the truck.
Well, it's possible.
Christina, what do you think?
AUDIENCE: I couldn't-- on
the bottom of this part
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The point of contact?
Is that what you're saying?
Anybody else?
What do you vote for?
Where do you want to put A?
AUDIENCE: Point of contact.
PROFESSOR: Point of contact, OK.
If you're using this equation,
and you're using these pieces,
you are using the concept
of a rotating frame.
If there's any omega
in the problem,
you'd better have a
rotating frame somewhere.
Unless you're using
polar coordinates,
which is sort of a
degenerate rotating frame.
So at this point, we're
going to make A here.
And you have a coordinate
system, little x1 y1,
and attach the A. So you
have an A x1 y1, here z1.
And is it rotating?
Is it a rotating
coordinate system?
Well, if it's not,
then you can't do this.
This assumes-- this term
here is the velocity
at which this point
and this point
are moving relative
to one another,
as if you were
sitting on the pipe.
Ignoring the-- you
don't see the rotation,
you're moving with the pipe.
It's assuming you have then put
a reference frame on the pipe
that moves with the pipe.
So does the little reference
frame, reference frame Axyz
move with the pipe?
It better, or you
can't use the equation.
So this is attached to the pipe.
And as it rolls, you have
to allow that xyz frame
to move with it.
OK.
So in that frame,
what's this term?
This is 0 because the two
points are fixed in the pipe.
And what's this velocity?
AUDIENCE: 3.
PROFESSOR: 3 meters per
second in what direction?
We'll do it in an
inertial frame if we want.
And then what's this term?
So it's 6, and we
said it doesn't
matter what frame it is,
it's all the same rotation
rate, radians per second.
In what direction?
k hat cross, the
radius is capital R,
what's this direction?
And now this is at
an instant in time.
At this particular
instant in time,
you've cleverly drawn the xyz
system so it lines up with them
after so it makes
the problem easy.
So at the moment, it's
either in the big J hat
or in the little j hat.
It's easiest if you do
it in big-- call it big
J, because then you're done.
So, k cross J, I
think negative I.
And so this should
work out to be
3 meters per second positive
I. 1 and 1/2 times 6 is
9 and a minus.
9 meters per second
in the I direction.
So you are at minus
6 meters per second.
AUDIENCE: Isn't the
radius from point G?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Wouldn't it be what?
AUDIENCE: Does it
matter if it's negative?
PROFESSOR: Ah, it matters a lot.
You have to exercise great care
when you pick the R vector.
And the R vector
goes from your origin
to the point you're
talking about.
So the origin, that's your
frame, and that's the point.
And when you draw the
arrow, the R vector,
it goes from A to G.
That's its direction.
And it has-- its length
is capital R long.
Yeah, that's a really,
really important point,
which way the arrows go.
OK, and so now we're
done with that.
Let's see, we've
got a minute or two.
Let's talk about
the acceleration.
Let's do the acceleration of
this problem, acceleration
of G in o, and this
is just an exercise
in remembering the terms.
Full 3D vector equation
for accelerations.
What's the first term here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: How about before
we even get into-- we're
not in polar
coordinates in this.
AUDIENCE: The
acceleration of A in o?
PROFESSOR: All right,
let's just work it out.
I start with this one
myself, acceleration of A
with respect to o.
What's another term?
AUDIENCE: Acceleration
of G with respect to A.
PROFESSOR: So the
acceleration of G
with respect to A, but
no rotation, right?
That term.
Plus, how many more
terms do we have to go?
Three, OK.
Give me one.
Somebody else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Stephen.
PROFESSOR: Stephen.
You've got a 2 omega,
and omega is-- let's
get this unit vector in here.
Well, actually let's not.
2 omega cross r,
let's just do that.
OK?
Give me another term.
Somebody else?
AUDIENCE: Omega
cross [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Omega
cross omega cross r.
And got another one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
and in fact, we'd
better be a little
more careful than that.
So it's really the velocity
of G with respect to A.
And does it have
rotation in it or not?
This is the no rotation.
This is the speed at which
the points are moving apart
from one another, right?
Omega cross omega cross
r, we've got-- one, two--
I think we need another term.
Omega dot cross r.
And the r is rGA, this r is GA.
OK, so what's the
acceleration of this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Nope.
AUDIENCE: Negative half.
PROFESSOR: So this
one's minus 1/2.
What's this one?
So you're in the
frame of the pipe now,
and this is the speed at
which the acceleration of G
with respect to A. It doesn't
move, it's fixed length, right?
This one, what's the velocity
of G with respect to A,
without rotation involved?
OK, and this one is omega k
cross, and this is our, again,
omega k cross.
And this RG, it's R in what
direction at this instant?
J, right?
So we could work that out.
And what about this one?
What direction is omega dot in?
k cross R, at this
instant, J again.
Do we know that value?
No.
That might be something
we have to figure out.
So you could now crank this out.
That'd be the acceleration
of that point,
but you'd find out that
we don't have that.
Now, how would you go about
finding out what omega dot is?
AUDIENCE: Equations of motion?
PROFESSOR: You
get the gold star.
Equations of motion.
You need to come up with
equations of motion.
And how many equations of
motion would we end up writing?
This is equivalent to asking
how many degrees of freedom
are there.
I hear 2, I hear a 1.
Now, there's a lot of
nuances to this discussion.
Anytime you're given a
fixed value for something,
that coordinate is constrained,
that parameter's constrained.
We're given the
motion of the truck.
It's completely specified.
You could just substitute
numbers in for those things.
I mean, like this,
it pops up as 1/2.
I think this thing will
boil down to one equation.
And you need to pick some set
of coordinates to describe it.
So if I'm looking
for omega dot, I'd
probably work with
torque about that point.
Isolated to just
this object, and this
is some of the torque
around this point,
and see what happens.
Some of the external torques
gotta be equal to what?
DH dt, and then you have
to sort out this term.
So in this problem,
you know-- what's
the direction of this velocity?
I. What is the unit
vector associated
with the linear
momentum of that pipe?
What direction is the
linear momentum of the pipe?
What's the velocity?
What is this answer?
What's the momentum
of that pipe?
Mass times that velocity, right?
Remember, the velocity
of the system, the pipe
may have all its
mass around the rim,
but the velocity of the
momentum of the pipe
is the total mass of the
pipe times the velocity
of its center of mass.
And that's the velocity
of the center of mass.
So its linear momentum has what
unit vector assigned with it?
I. And what is the unit
vector was associated with vA?
I. I cross I is?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: So this is
one of those cases where
they're parallel paths,
and that term drops out.
So you could come up with
it very quickly and easily.
Equation of motion.
OK.
Very good.
See you on Tuesday.
Next Tuesday lecture
time will be review.
I think it's gonna be more
like one of these sessions,
and then quiz Tuesday night.